[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
how many species of animals do we really
need dude i but hold on just tell me how
many we really need i i could use more
if i if how great would it be if we
started discovering new species we do
every day there's a new beetle or
something like that but we don't need it
i wish they would interbreed like a lion
and a gorilla and we could get a like oh
i'm [ __ ] upset garion a grind that
sounds like an asian person saying lion
wait a minute so okay so like if if a
thing goes extinct that's like really
like when the world
rhinoceros goes extinct have you ever
seen a bald eagle
no oh
let me tell you something
i grew i'm a little older than you so i
grew up when bald eagles were like
facing extinction yeah i remember the
first time i saw bald eagle i was in
alaska yeah one of those bush jet boats
yeah and we saw baldy going on and
everyone i was with was like everyone
was my age you're like holy [ __ ] a bald
eagle they're [ __ ] huge yeah and
they're beautiful and you're like holy
[ __ ] a bald eagle and like lost our
minds but i feel like we could do that
with a kite we could make a nice kite
right like we could make a beautiful
ornate kite and then just hang them up
for whatever they tried to bring
everybody loves raymond to russia uh-huh
and it just didn't work because they
were like he was like who let their
woman talk like that
you hit her you hit her a little bit and
say [ __ ] you don't talk to me like that
my mom's born and raised in scotland
comes here like in her mid-20s yeah no
yeah yeah no oh okay oh man this is all
changing yeah most people assume i'm
jewish right everyone assumes you jewish
yeah not jewish you're just new york i'm
just new york right and the name so kind
of you know fits the bill and then um
so basically yes so she comes in the 20
when she's in her 20s and she was just
she was a dancer my parents went to
dance school it's all like dance lessons
that's why i loved your video
yeah yeah yeah your parents were danced
my mom was a three-time us ballroom
dance champion
i mean this is not you know you know
this is like blowing my [ __ ] mind
yeah yeah there is a rat right across
yeah i know is that okay we have
chickens back there okay guys so the
rats go in to eat i see i see yeah yeah
yeah unpredictable gotta move gotta move
[Laughter]
time to go
we have a queen palm and i brought my
drone up yesterday to go to the top of
the queen palm and there are rats
everywhere it's like the secret of nim
like they're just it you gotta go the
hardest thing in your life i imagine as
a gay dude is coming out right the
subscribers you come out
you got to do that
over and over again every time you go on
stage
like if like for me that that's why i
always assume that there's like the
super flamboyant gays that's their
version of coming out without saying it
it's like if i'm in [ __ ] pink shorts
and rollerblades
you know i'm gay so i don't have to go
hey i'm gay
but a guy like like for example a guy
like tim dillon that you would never
assume is gay hilarious comic he's got
to let everyone know he's gay and then
when he says it they're like man come on
he's like no no seriously i'm gay i like
[ __ ] dicks he says it like that yeah
you're like are you what's going on here
the first time you did rogan i think me
and a couple people texted like should
any of us text joe and let him know he's
gay like not that joe would joe's not
that kind of like hateful guy and he
would never say anything right but it is
an interesting sidebar to know of tim
when you meet him you're like yeah well
shut up like i remember
i remember being a little heartbroken
when i found out he was gay like not
that it matters like i don't go out and
chase tail yeah i don't i all like i was
like oh like i don't know what i was
more upset that he didn't drink or that
he was gay like i was like i was like
come on there's gotta be something the
interview i saw was about chappelle it
was a it was from uh
a tran a train it was a guy who spanish
spells from young turks and uh and this
transgendered um
lady yeah i think i don't know if i
always [ __ ] it up it's uh she was a man
she's a woman now whatever [ __ ] that's
what i call it
so yeah you just there's so many rats
it's like
there's like you've seen it
there's like five six rats just
converging
dude it is oh my god bro there's i've
there's ten i've seen ten rats
right across from where we're doing
oh my god you're not joking and bro
there's a fake owl that's meant to scare
them off i think that's the point of the
owl right oh my god that that is more
rats than i've ever seen in that kit in
that cage ever in my life dude you do a
good job of like pretending like you
don't see that regularly oh it doesn't
bother me anymore oh my god bro that's
so many rats
you know we had them we had them in our
house
we had them in our house
but when we and we you could hear them
in the attic yeah and they were just
living in the attic yeah and um we had
to have a we had to have an exterminator
come out and they got up in the attic
and he was like oh
there's like
a [ __ ] nest yeah so they had to seal
off the attic and then for a week
we watched dudes that have been on
vacation like rats have been on vacation
try to get back into their family oh
i know this is crazy i know i'm gonna
sound like a lunatic yeah but it breaks
your heart to see a rat be like
my family's in there have you heard
about forest bathing what forest bathing
no you got to do this while you're out
when you go home uh wait wait where's
baby hold on
okay i go i go home tomorrow but then i
go to russia
what are you doing in russia i'm doing a
show in russia where where where um
moscow have you performed in russia no
you gotta go if there's anybody that's
gotta go
if there's anybody there's something to
russia talk to your promoters sergey and
tell them to hit me up
you've really had collusion like
how big of a venue are you doing in
moscow i think it's like maybe 400 seats
something like [ __ ] huge yeah it's
pretty crazy we got a call one time i
was my youngest right
dyslexic really dyslexic right how does
she spell her name
not right
you gave me the trickiest [ __ ] name
this [ __ ] idiot wrote on her pe
jersey isla k but put all the letters
too close and was mark tardy absent for
the entire semester because the teacher
thought her name was ilac
and so
and so um
she
we got a phone that's a really
interesting statement we got a phone
call one day we were looking at houses
me and leanne and
um we got a call from the school and
they're like there's been an incident at
the school yeah and we're like okay and
they're like what's going on they're
like someone is uh threatened to murder
isla and immediately we're like you got
the right kid okay and then they're like
no it's it's actually more serious than
that he said he's gonna go and get a gun
and bring it tomorrow and we're like all
right they're like we just want to give
you a heads up and immediately we're
like what did you do to the kid and i
was like what do you mean what did i do
how come i'm to blame and you're like
because no one just threatens to murder
literally the kid's getting kicked out
of school he's no longer in school he's
no longer in that school what did you do
to start this because i don't believe
it's just that kid yeah she was like dad
sometimes it's just that kid i go no
sometimes it's not like what did you do
and she was okay well if you if you had
to put blame on anyone it would really
be on my friend
but yeah but like it's interesting we
victim blame this idea that you
shouldn't victim blame is is absurd
because we literally victim blame with
every dif if you come home and there's
something spilled on the carpet
you are blaming well i guess the carpet
is would be the victim in that
circumstance but it doesn't matter
whatever the [ __ ] it is you victim blame
and and like did you just lay there
just get walked all over all day you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you get walked on all
[ __ ] day you never stand up for
yourself and now you got ketchup on you
well you deserve it we were talking
about uh they were like uh [ __ ] what was
it uh that the china is made the most
advanced facial recognition software in
the world it's like
dig better
i could see a couple people counted
twice
whatever hill you find to die on that's
going to be your hill yeah and our
daughter's learning disabled what does
she have severely um
school
what do you mean oh what does she have
oh oh i thought you said where's she at
i said school
she's in the basement
it's really bad if there's a repetitive
task asians will be the best at it
because they can sit there and just do
the same thing over and over again
longer than anyone else
indians are probably second they'll do
it pretty close but like white and black
kids like we're gonna be like i
i'm gonna jerk off do you know me
snorkelers get eaten up by whales every
year because they're whale watching and
all of a sudden the plankton rush at
them and my my buddy john
[ __ ] and you're you get caught up and it
just
whale's gotta go
they gotta go
okay that's what animal has struck all
in your heart where you went
holy [ __ ] no dog's gotta stay no no no
no like all dogs never give me all yeah
i i saw a lion one time i was like 15
feet from a lion okay in
in the safari safari
it's a majestic animal so and then you
looked at it right and then when you
were done looking it right i was done
before everyone else and that that's
interesting you say that because i
remember everyone was like whoa and i
was like i got it yeah same with the
whale shark we went scuba diving whale
sharks and they're like we're gonna go
down there for 45 minutes and i was like
cool and we got down there and i was
like five minutes in i'm like i am done
with this [ __ ] whale shark
yeah right yeah it whale sharks kind of
a [ __ ] whale shark it's like you eat
something dog he's just sitting there
doing the net like he was in japan they
had netted him so you could like they
take people out and just oh [ __ ] sad
that's all i'm saying is like
we don't have to have all the animals
and we're we're spending all this time
trying to save some yeah and i think
it's like
god is going it's kind of better without
without that
about a guy who [ __ ] the chimpanzee
yeah you know that's how like i don't
remember the bit but he was basically
saying someone said that like a
chimpanzee a guy [ __ ] a chimpanzee and
that's how aids spread right because he
[ __ ] chimpanzees and then he was
[ __ ] humans and he was like uh you
really think that there's a guy out
there who was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
chimpanzee on sunday and then [ __ ]
charlene
on a tuesday and then and then he got
and then he has this act out where he
goes uh
charlene says a great name but he has
zagged out where he goes he goes he goes
fellas i'm sorry i gotta hang out with
my
he goes you guys he goes you don't know
how hard it is uh to get your chimpanzee
to suck your dick
without peeling it
but like that's silly we're talking
about a heavy topic we're talking about
the absurdity of that you know
justification for aids but the the the
it's a dick joke at the end of the day
yeah it's a silly thing at the end of
the day dick joke a suck dick banana
joke at the end of the day and it's like
if you lose that you lose comment the
hilarious thing to me is like
especially when like the foreign comics
come to america and then just like [ __ ]
on america and it's like you beg to be
here
you begged bro you had to fill out an
extensive like visa application where
america basically goes hey you better
kiss my [ __ ] taint if you want to be
in america and you go well where is your
taint
uncle sam where's your team i'd love to
kiss it and the second you get in you're
like well how could these republicans do
this and these everybody in the south is
stupid it's like are you [ __ ] kidding
me it's crazy that it's crazy that we'll
let it happen do you realize how foreign
that would be if you went to a foreign
country they would crucify in america
and you're like the north of england is
a bunch of [ __ ] window licking like
everyone would be like who the [ __ ] are
you yeah who invited you here to talk
[ __ ] about us like dude it is
mind-boggling to me that we even allow
it like i i haven't that we even allow
it dude i remember getting into a fight
with because you don't care like you
don't care you don't care enough because
if you really cared about like helping a
country you would start with yours
right like you would start with your
[ __ ] country right but you don't care
about helping a country you just want to
be famous and here's the best place to
be famous and the lane for fame that
they gave you was [ __ ] all over half of
america which is fine but at least look
me in the face and go dude i'm a fame
[ __ ] i don't care about nothing i i
don't care about none of this [ __ ] i
don't care about who they vote for i
don't care about donald trump i don't
care about hillary i care about another
i just want to make millions of dollars
and i can't do that in my shitty country
but the idea that we allow it like how
generous and kind are we oh it's
astounding we let people come to our
country and make millions of dollars
trashing half of it because the balls
the the the unbelievable arrogance that
that takes to think that you should be
able to do that and walk around the
streets the fact you don't get punched
in your head the fact that you don't get
pushed in your [ __ ] head
it's astonishing japanese
and like upper east side jews are the
exact opposite people
like like by the way i'm so excited for
this analogy you have no [ __ ] idea
because you know how like everything
about japanese culture is don't uh make
anyone else uncomfortable by any means
do not embarrass anybody don't
inconvenience any whatever you do do not
inconvenience a single soul right you
know like upper east side jewish culture
is like it's cold
why turn the heat up
why is this so toasted it's constantly
what can i do in this moment for me to
feel
me to feel more comfortable yeah and i
so i the first thing i did when i got
back i hit my boy dove and i was like
no no dove man dove mammon uh
and i asked him because he travels a lot
does a lot of stuff and uh i go dude i
was just in japan like what's your take
in japan and he goes don't even get me
started
i just feel like there's a lot of
animals that it's time to go
and we're holding on too long okay like
this house you have rats everywhere
it's time to go right like like
i all i see is rat tails hanging hanging
down like little icicles by the way i
can't not see them now too my scene is
directed i feel like this is an
intimidation tactic that you learned in
russia like i feel like this is this is
a way to like get the guests i mean i
can't believe how many rats are in there
i can't believe it
yeah it's shocking i can't realize
that's the only takeaway anyone will get
from this podcast is like bert's got
rats yeah
there will be animations there will be
like that's where people will hang their
hat on this podcast you could be like
you know actually
i uh bro there are
no less than 50 rats going up and down
and they're more they're coming down the
tree
this is like you got to call this city
you gotta you gotta get you gotta call
the city you gotta scare them or
something
why are you going outside we are safe
from them in here you got to scare them
halston don't scare them they'll come in
here close the door
just close the door close the door
we're not doing this i'd love for
holston to be attacked by why is he
doing that this is something i don't get
but that's what i'm saying so a
rhinoceros oh my god
okay now when you see all that could we
live without rats what if rats just no
you couldn't see but don't give me the
whole thing the ecosystem falls yeah
yeah it doesn't
because we've been killing animals
forever and we're pretty good yeah but
uh
what's i don't know yeah maybe we could
live without rats personally i could
live without rats so now we just take it
now what about polar bears
i've never i've never needed one
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]